let's go to lynn in brownsville texas
lynn how we doing
oh good sir how are you i'm all right
uh well my question is
my husband continues to hide debt from
me
and the huge debt i found out recently
i confronted him and he didn't really
say anything
and he doesn't want to pay it off
quickly like i do
and then i found out he was hiding other
than a credit card debt and he still
hasn't come complete clean about it and
i haven't confronted him yet so i'm
wondering how i should respond
wow so it's less about hiding he's just
lying to you what's what's the debt
um the first one was a student loan and
he
he asked me if it was okay if he got a
student loan for about seven thousand
and i didn't really want him to do it
but
he but then i was like okay that's fine
you can just do it but you have to put
in your name i'm not
doing i'm not close signing and then it
just built up from there
i later found out it was 24 000 by the
time he graduated
and um and then i
found out about that because i got an
inheritance and i wanted to use that to
pay off
the debt and then he kept going around
it
not admitting and finally by the end of
the day he admitted it was 24 000 it was
way over the inheritance amount
so um and then the second one
i found out he put about 500 on a credit
card to enroll in a master's program
and he went behind my back on that
because
he asked if he could enroll in a
master's and i said no
i think we need to pay off this other
student loan first
and i guess he enrolled in the master's
charged it to the credit card but then
backed out because
he couldn't handle it and he hasn't told
me about that one yet
what's what's the state of your marriage
outside of this this
it i work for dave ramsey as you
probably know and yeah they call it
financial infidelity what's what's the
state of your marriage outside of this
financial infidelity
um it's okay we're a blended family so
we have no children together but we've
been married 10 years
and emotionally it's pretty well i'm
actually the one that suppresses my
feelings like you're talking about
but he doesn't he's like very open with
his feelings for the most part he always
wants to talk about things
but we're just not on the same page on
debt it sounds
very maternal like you are the adult
mom in the family and he's the kid
because
i my alarm systems go off anytime
somebody says my husband came and asked
me if he could buy this
and my response was well i'm not going
to co-sign for you
the reality is y'all got a 10-year
marriage his debts your debts your debts
his debt right so you're already in on
this but
are you more the mom or his wife
yeah it feels kind of like that but we
agree to come to each other
if we want to spend over 50 on anything
and we
discuss the budget but he kind of is
passive about it
he's like goes along with it but i'm
i've always been the dave ramsey even
before we got married
and my husband isn't doesn't agree with
all of that
like paying off debt quickly and all
that is he
is he cheat on you in other ways too
um i've i've found out over the years
he's lied about other things
and i wasn't aware of it in the
beginning of her marriage i guess it
just wasn't
i i've tried to look all the good things
about him so i just kind of
i didn't look into it i wasn't skeptical
then then
recently yes there's things other things
he's lied to me about in the past
has he cheated on you with other women
no
no okay so he just lies to you and and
about certain things and then spends
money that y'all agreed you wouldn't
spend
okay so here's the deal it sounds like
you've got a super immature husband
and at some point i'm gonna say you're
being immature too because at some point
you've got to draw these boundaries
and you've got to say either this is
just the guy i married
i'm not going to lose any sleep over it
i want to be like this but he doesn't
want to so so be it
or at some point you're going to have to
draw hard boundaries
and sit down and say here's who we
i want to be in our house i want to
vision together and dream together
and then you have to have this is really
uncomfortable you have to have an or
what
an or what
or you're going to have this hard
conversation and put these boundaries in
place and he's going to say
no i'm not doing that dude i want to go
to grad school again and i'm not paying
off debt i think dave ramsey's an idiot
i think delony's an idiot i don't want
to do any of those things
and you just you're going to call it
are you going to leave what are you
going to do and so this
clearly is a situation that you can't
handle by yourself and i don't say that
negatively
it means you need a third party you need
a counselor of some sort
and so what i'm gonna strongly recommend
is that you tell him
hey you need to see somebody on your
head i'm gonna go see somebody because
i've got to get some practice building
boundaries i've got to get some practice
standing up to a husband who's lying to
me all the time and
the more you find out about dishonesty
after a decade
i'm telling you right now there's going
to be more there and more there and more
there
because where a guy is lying about money
yeah yeah sure with the same budget cool
and then they go spend it and not just
seven thousand
and no it wasn't actually that it was
three times plus that it was twenty five
thousand dollars twenty four thousand
dollars
oh and by the way this and you find it
about more lives i promise you there's
more there
and what you need is a third party and
my gut tells me
you know that my gut tells me that deep
inside
you know something isn't right something
is a little bit wishy-washy
and i want you to get some professional
help and care my hope is he'll go with
you
if he won't if he won't go with you
then that's a bigger red flag and you're
going to need to sit with a therapist
with a pastor with somebody you trust
to walk out to kind of iron out what
next steps are going to be
and you are a blended family so my guess
is this isn't your first time
down this road my guess is that your
heart is breaking because
uh gosh i've been down this train tracks
before and i know where this leads
and so it's on you to to stick a flag in
the ground and say not this time
i'm gonna double down on myself i'm
gonna double down on my marriage and
you just gotta be able to call it on
yourself and say i don't have the i
don't have the strength or the skill set
to do this on my own i got to get a
professional
so that's my recommendation to you lynn
um
let me know how that conversation goes i
want you i want to know what it's what
happens when you sit down and you look
at him and say
this stops you've been lying to me for a
decade we're going to see somebody and
we're getting
all the truth all the crap out on the
table
and then we're going to work together
i'm not your mom i am your wife
i am your partner i am your lover ew
no lover mom mixes right lin no lover
mom mixes i am your wife not your mom
we do things together
no more permission giving no more that
nonsense yeah and let's get it on the
table let me know how that goes i'm
gonna be fascinated to find out
if he steps up or if he goes i just want
to play
i just want to play fortnite i just want
to play fortnite and go away